The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
All right.
So we're going to
continue now and kind of
get into the examples
part of the course.
And again, this
is really the part
that people should really--
I strongly encourage
people doing examples.
How many people got a
chance to try the examples
in the-- very good.
And we got a couple of
questions for people.
And most of the time we got
another e-mail from them
right away that said,
no, got it to work.
So we're very
pleased about that.
The great thing about
working at Lincoln Labs
is people are pretty good
at figuring stuff out.
We have some experience
this and before.
Obviously, our parallel
MATLAB technology,
we've release that out.
Many, many people use it.
And for the most part,
we're proud to say
that whenever we get a question
from the outside world,
and it's not
working, it's usually
the person hasn't taken
severely active steps to ignore
the documentation.
But if they follow it at all,
they're generally pretty safe.
So I'm going to get into
the example code here.
So the example code this
is-- oh, that's not,
D4Muser_share, that's incorrect.
It's tools lower case examples.
I should correct these slides.
Oh, nice.
There we go.
Great.
That is an x, right?
I hope so.
Oh yes, thank you.
Great.
All right.
So this is where
the example code is.
We're going to go over here.
Your assignment, should
you choose to undertake it,
is to pick a picture,
hopefully something
that's interesting to you.
Doesn't have to
be straight lines,
it could be anything where
you could create, draw edges,
or something, you
could take some photo
and put it through one of
those Photoshop effects
and turn it into a line
drawing or something
and then start
labeling vertices.
You do want to limit the
number of lines though.
I would recommend
20 would be the most
number of lines you do.
Because this can
get fairly involved.
You might start with
something fairly small.
So select a picture.
Label the edges and vertices.
Create an incidence matrix.
And then just compute
the adjacency matrix
from the instance matrix
using this formula.
You can certainly use d4m
if you want to do that.
But it's fine to do it by hand.
It's fine to do it by
hand, in which case
you'd want to a very small one.
Doing it once by hand is useful.
Twice marginally.
And then the third
time, not useful.
Just like in high school, right?
They make you do
matrix multiplied
by hand like actually a lot.
A lot.
So that's the example
in the assignment.
If you do this on
a piece of paper
and scan it and email it to
me before the next lecture,
I will give you
some feedback on it
before the following lecture.
If you give it to me
after that too bad.
I just won't give you feedback.
So there's no credit.
But this gives you some
incentive to get it done.
If you want feedback from me
about what you did makes sense
or if you encountered
like I picked this picture
and now I don't
understand-- I did my best
but I have questions
about how I did this.
Does it make sense?
I'd be happy to do that.
So just scan it, email it to me,
or if it is electronic format
you can do that as well.
So the lecture portion
and now go back here.
And let's see here,
we go to examples.
All right.
So we're in the intro,
EdgeArt directory,
start my MATLAB shell.
MATLAB.
This takes about 15
seconds for it to do this.
This particular
thing always CDs me
to the location
of the directory.
You need to do that in
order to see the examples.
I think most MATLAB users
are familiar with that.
But just some that are not.
Here is the actual adjacency
matrix of that painting.
So there it is.
Same thing we just saw.
So this is the data set that
we're going to work with here.
So I'm going to do EA1.
Again, all the examples
are numbered in order,
kind of that you're supposed
to proceed through them.
And if see a file in
a directory that's
like couple capital letters,
which are the first two
letters of the directory or the
abbreviation of the directory
in a test, that is the examples.
The other files are
just supporting files.
You are not expected
to run those.
You can try running them
but they'll probably
cause you problems if you
run them by themselves.
All right, here we go.
So we just ran that example.
Let's see what we got.
I think that worked.
So the first thing we did
here is we read in our data.
So we have this Read CSV,
very useful function.
Not necessarily the fastest.
In some of the later
examples we have a sort
of a super fast
reader, which does
almost no formatting for you.
Just reads in the
triples as raw triples.
Because a lot of times if you're
reading a very large CSV file,
you may not want to construct
the full associative
array out of the way we
would just do it by default.
And you can just read in
the triples very quickly
then do some manipulations.
Or a lot of times the
first thing you'll do
is recreate an associated array
and then get the triples out
of it, because you want to
work on the triples directly.
And so we do have
ways for doing that.
So we now created
the incidence matrix
into an associative array.
And let me just show you that.
So if I go disp(E), so that
shows you the incidence matrix.
These are its internal
structures here.
These are the row keys.
So those are the
labels of the edges.
They have been converted to
Luxor graphically sorted order.
We have the column keys.
But there's so many that
MATLAB chooses not to print out
the full list here.
But it's again, a Luxor
graphically sorted
list of the unique labels.
These are the different
values that we have.
So you remember we had
an order column, which
is one, two, three, blue, green,
orange, pink, silver, etc.
And here and then the
overall adjacency matrix,
which connects the row keys to
their value keys is 19 by 21.
19 rows by 21 columns.
This actually shows a mixed use.
Some of these are
essentially exploded, right?
The fact that we have each edge.
But some of the
values are actually
storing real stuff here.
Blue, green, orange, etc.
So you don't have to go
all the way with one.
You can mix them too around.
You can create dense
matrices that look more
like traditional tables.
And there's sometimes
that you want to do that.
And other times
you can completely
explode it out and do
things like that as well.
So we go back.
We just want to work
with the vertices.
So we're going to ignore
this color and order columns.
So we're going to create
our first projection is
to just work with the vertices.
So we have this little shorthand
here called StartsWith,
if you give it a character.
And it will create
a little query
that will get just things
that start with that.
And very useful thing.
It's very efficient too.
It actually formally
creates the two boundaries.
It figures out what the
maximum range is for that.
And then just needs to look
up the beginning and the end.
It [? can ?] [? assume ?]
lexicographical order and then
it can just grab the middle.
We have a regular
expression approach to it,
which works fine on
small associative arrays.
But this is much more
efficient because it's just
basically two lookups and go.
It also works if this E was
actually a binding to a table
in a database.
You can use this same syntax,
while the regular expression
syntax doesn't really work.
Yes?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So that's the
delimiter of the string.
It's a string list
with one entry in it.
So this is a string list.
All our strings are lists here.
Well, because this
also allows me--
could've been anything
that was unique to that.
And it didn't have to be
the same delimiter that
was the one inside.
It could have been a new
line, could have been a tab,
could move whatever.
I just picked comma
because it was convenient
but could have been a space.
Because you could have multiple
arguments to the StartsWith.
If you want to say I want starts
with this and starts with this
and starts with this, you
just give it a whole list
and it will go and
do that all for you.
And so that's why
we do it that way.
Wherever possible, we try
and accept a list of strings.
And then do the right thing.
So basically, this
is saying, get me
all columns that
start with V. So that
would be all the vertices.
And this is the colon,
which as you know
and I want the full row of that.
These had these values
of-- which were the order
group that they were in.
And so we don't
care about those.
We want to convert them back
to regular numeric numbers.
And so we have
this shorthand here
called double Logi, which
basically just takes
the logical and then does the
double thing mathematically.
Formally, you would use to
call this the infinity norm
on strings, if that
even makes sense.
But it basically just says, if
there's a value there converted
to a double precision one.
If there's not a value there,
it's just a sparse 0, not--
And we do this all
the time because a lot
of times we want to do
math on these things.
It's like regular math.
We want to compute the
vertex adjacency graph.
So we do that with
our square in function
here, our inner square product.
So that basically
takes our matrix
and uses the edge as the common
key to join them together.
And we use or
display full function
to actually show what we got.
And so now you see the
vertex adjacency matrix here.
And then the number
is the number
of times those vertices
are on the same edge.
So it's obviously symmetric.
And you see here
these vertices here,
which are part of this
common hyper edge,
we have this sort of
6 9 6 structure here,
various other types of
symmetric structures
going on here showing
you the counts,
how many times those vertices
appeared on the same edge.
These are obviously
cliques, because they
are all vertices that are
on the same hyper edge line.
So if you have the
same hyper edge
line whenever you do
the squaring operation,
you see it as this clique
in this operation here.
We can also do the square
out function, which computes
the edge adjacency matrix.
So now we want to ask, which
edges share common vertices?
And so that's this
structure here.
It shows you these
are the various edges.
And again, it's symmetric.
And you can see all
kinds of structures
in here about which
vertices share-- which
edges share common vertices.
And that is pretty much
it for this example.
Very simple example.
Hopefully it gets
you to the point
where you can begin to try
out the homework assignment.
And if there's any
questions that people have,
let's try this.
Here, one thing that's
fun to do spy(E).
See if that works.
I think between PowerPoint,
Quick Time and everything
else it's just
about-- there it is.
Wow, that took a long time.
So this shows that
adjacency matrix.
So spy works.
And I don't know if we showed
that in the first example,
but the spy function, the
standard MATLAB sparse plotting
function, very useful way to
just sort of look at the stuff,
all those previous charts I
showed you on the examples
were done this thing.
And a little feature
that sometimes
causes MATLAB to crash
because it doesn't really like
doing things too aggressively.
But if you click on it, it
shows you the row and the column
and the value
associated with that,
and also prints it out here.
Likewise here.
So you see row, column,
that gives you the order.
And this tells you the row
is G2, its column, its color,
its value is green.
So actually, I lied to you.
That was just the first example.
Senior moment there.
We have two more to go.
Lot more fun.
See, you're all excited
that class ended early.
Here's the other examples.
So again, what we do is we're
reading in the data set.
We're displaying the full thing.
So you can see there's the
full beast I just showed you
the spy plot.
Now, I'm going to use
some analytics on this.
So one thing I want to do is
just get the orange edges.
So I can say, get
me the column color.
And because orange
is held in the value,
I can actually compare
it with the string.
So I say, return me the
matrix, the associative array
of the row, color and
everything equal to orange.
So that returns me
another associative array.
The result of this
whole logical expression
is another associative array.
I can then get the rows for
those associative arrays.
And I've found all
edges that are orange.
And I can then pass
that, get those rows
and pass that back
into the original one
to get just the orange edges.
So this just shows you
this composable ability
is very powerful, same
ability that MATLAB has.
One does similar statements
in MATLAB all the time.
And so it's very composable.
This would be a
very complex query
to do in other approaches.
And you can do it
very quickly here.
Yes?
Question?
[INAUDIBLE] would that
be called to route
since it is in the row with
the argument [INAUDIBLE]?
No.
It doesn't.
What we could do is
overload it so if you passed
an associative array with
just a single argument
and have it behave like when
you pass in the MATLAB logical
and do that kind
of intersection,
we could think about that.
But MATLAB actually
relies on then converting
the matrix to a vector and
then using that singular--
basically, it takes that
logical, converts it
to a single [? index, ?]
which kind of gets us
into an area where it's
very fuzzy and gray.
So we definitely
thought about that
and there are places where we
line up with MATLAB very nicely
because the mathematics
of associative arrays
and linear algebra really
line up very nicely.
And there's places
where they intersect.
There's things you can do
in with associative arrays
that you can't do
with linear algebra.
For example, we can matrix
multiply any two associative
arrays.
There's no conformance
requirements.
That is, they don't have
the same-- normally,
when you multiply two matrices--
the inner dimensions have
to match, basically.
The columns of the left
argument and the rows
of the right argument
must be the same length.
In associative arrays that
requirement doesn't exist.
You can multiply or add
any two associative arrays.
We'll get into that much
more in the next class.
But that's a very powerful
feature that people like.
But there's other places where
it doesn't really make sense.
So things like, what is the
upper triangular section
of an associative array gets to
be a little bit-- huh, what's
that mean?
So excellent question though.
Excellent question though.
So we can display this.
So this just shows we
found all the edges that
had color orange.
But we don't have to
just-- that's a way
of using the values to select.
We could, of course, use
StartsWith in the rows,
just say StartsWith
O and G. I just
happened to label all my rows
that orange rows began with O
and green rows begin with G.
So we can do StartsWith
O G. So that's
example of those two
range queries being
done at the same time.
And so that gives us EOG.
And again, we can see now we
get the orange and green rows.
So that just shows you that.
And then we'll wrap up here with
the last example, which is EA3.
Now, we get to do
some really fun stuff.
Again, we're reading
in our data set,
converting, just
getting the vertices.
And then converting it
to numeric 0's and 1's.
I'm going to now just
get the orange edges.
And I'm going to
get the green edges.
All right.
And now I'm going to essentially
do the cross correlation
of the orange and green edges.
So I'm going to
transpose one of them
and matrix multiply
with the other ones.
We don't do square
in here because they'
are different matrices.
In fact, I would say
that people often
do the cross-correlation
more often
than just square the
matrix with itself.
You have one set
with another set
and you want to cross correlate
them, a very common operation.
And so that's just
transpose EVG here.
And that gets that.
And as you can see, the
results of that inner product
was empty.
But the result of the
outer product is full.
So you guys can think
about why that is.
And so this just shows you the
common-- how many edges these
appeared with together.
This shows you that
there was no-- well,
you guys can figure that out.
I'll let you do your homework.
Now, another thing that we
often want to do is basically,
this showed us which edges
had common shared vertices
together.
But it didn't tell us we
lost the actual vertices.
We just know that there's three.
And a lot of times we want them.
This is sometimes
called the pedigree.
You do a correlation.
And then you would
like-- you say these two
things are correlated.
I want to get to the connector
back to the original record
so I can go back to
my e-matrix and really
find that out and present
that as the evidence
that these things are
connected together.
We don't want to lose that.
So we have invented special
new matrix multiplies
in the land of
associative arrays.
One of them we call
a CatKeyMul, which
you view the matrix
multiply as sort of there's
a key, a common key,
this row column key
that's being joined together.
Well, we can preserve that
and store that in a value,
instead of say the count
or something like that.
So we do CatKeyMul
EV0 transpose EVG.
And then when we display
that, we not only
see which edges were
connected, but we also
have preserved the
list of the vertices.
It's essentially a
concatenated list
of those keys,
very useful thing.
One has to be so very
powerful technique.
One definitely has to be careful
about using this technique
if it generates.
It's going to generate
extremely, extremely long lists
here.
That can really cause us
to behave very slowly.
In particular, when
asked to be careful,
if you do a CatKeyMul
on a matrix with itself,
why do you think you would
have to be careful with that?
Anyone?
Remember, that dense
diagonal that happened
whenever we squared matrices?
So that means this thing
will have an enormous number
of entries along the diagonal.
So you have to be
very careful when
you use this kind of function
to correlate something
with itself.
It's better to correlate
two distinct sets
because they tend to not have
that dense diagonal, which can
be a little bit of a problem.
There's ways to get around that.
There's hacks and tricks
and stuff like that.
But at a certain level,
really dense diagonala--
I mean, essentially be
listing every single vertex
in your data set-- you could
be listing every single vertex
in your data set almost every
single time, multiple times
along the diagonal.
That would get very, very bulky.
So just a little word
of caution there.
And so now, I've
baited you once.
But this really is the end.
So are there any
questions on the examples
before we cut it off here?
Is there a question
back here somewhere?
No?
All right.
Great.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
And we'll see you next week.
And again, think of a
picture, draw some lines,
make an incidence
matrix, have fun with it,
compute the degree of
your significant other.
Bad idea?
Good.